Queen Janine oh my goodness upset to see
you go this week first of all you're so
beautiful oh second of all you were one
of my favorite players on this season I
loved watching you every week I was
really rooting for you and especially
this week I was really hoping that you
guys were gonna flip the game on its
head because I feel like there are
certain people that are running the show
right now so how are you feeling now
that the episode has aired and
everything's inspired oh well first of
all thank you so much for the support I
oh it makes my heart sing
um but yeah it's it is difficult to
watch back because I think you just kind
of relive it all and you're like oh what
if I could have done you know that one
other thing or in hearing you know Cody
talk about how this game is played in
centimeters it's so true it's so um
anything can turn a tide a certain way
and it was disappointing at the time to
see that people especially in the
minority Alliance didn't want to shake
things up and you know there wasn't
enough momentum to like overturn things
because it was so close five seven
um but uh yeah that's just that's the
way that the cookie crumbled last night
and here I am as as the first juror
yeah absolutely so first let's Circle
back to last week's Tribal Council you
were blindsided Again by that vote and
you were under the impression that your
idol uh was gone that Dwight had left
with it so what was going through your
head going into the next week with the
immunity Challenge and strategy and all
that I mean I knew I was on the bottom I
was
um I knew that every
second of every day with like this is an
uphill battle and I'm going to have to
be really
um Scrappy and really try to figure out
any sort of cracks in this majority
lines any sort of
um potential allies that will be willing
to vote with or work with me moving
forward and with the immunity challenge
it was never a question of me sitting
out I was like
I don't care if it's something that I
know and have proven time and time again
that I can't do I need to you know play
to at least try to secure myself some
something in this game yeah
um but
um yeah so that's kind of where my mind
was at with Dwight leaving and with um
my idol being gone I was like I don't
have nowhere to hide I don't have
protection
So speaking of your idol after watching
it back I don't know about you but as a
viewer I was shocked to learn that
Dwight had given your idol to Jesse and
Jesse had it the whole time and you
obviously had no idea so yeah what's
your reaction to that obviously you
can't spoil like when you found out and
whatever but like what are your thoughts
on that
um my reaction is I have a couple of
reactions and the first is like wow like
I am just so impressed and and honestly
like grateful and happy that my baby
didn't die in Dwight's crotch
that it was you know repurposed and and
was able to like continue in the game
and
um the amount of effort that it took the
Blood Sweat and Tears that it took for
me to assemble that um you know didn't
actually go down the drain the way that
I thought it would so I also just think
I'm like it's so crazy because as a fan
as as a player it's like devastating and
as a fan it's like oh my God this is
incredible drama like I love it you know
yeah I feel the exact same way I my jaw
dropped I was like oh my gosh I couldn't
believe it
um so going back to this week and Owen
winning immunity and going to Tribal
Council were you
feeling like it was going to be you that
night or were you really hoping okay
this vote is going to flip to Ryan
because obviously that's kind of what
was discussed around camp but as a
viewer everything was very flip-floppy
it was both it was I was very aware of
the fact that um it was Ryan or or me
going home I knew that there was a huge
chance that I was going home again up
against a lot and even in that day in
the hours leading up to Tribal Council I
was kind of like
you know like
the fact that I wasn't feeling great
about it I was toying with the idea of
playing my shot in the dark and all
these things but I it's hard because in
this new era um
you can't
you you can't play too hard you can't be
squirming and that almost puts more of a
Target on your back right and so
it's like almost it's almost like
everything that could Advantage you in
the game
um like having more conversation
strategy thing more looking for the idol
those are things that also could place
or turn off people from wanting to work
with you and so they're your hands I
honestly was a bit paralyzing at that
point to be like I'm in this position I
don't feel great about
um the people that I'm supposed to be
trusting but what else am I supposed to
do like I I kind of feel like
um your back is up against the wall and
and you can either choose to trust which
I did because I felt like that was the
best thing for my long-term game to be
able to
um have allies of looking forward and
not put them off and working with me or
I can
um go off my rocker and like
you know try to
find an idol in the last minute or
um play you know in a really like crazy
game that would just blow it up and
maybe
maybe allow me to say another day but um
where do I go from there yeah absolutely
and speaking of Ryan again circling back
to watching things back what did you
think of his little speech as he was
writing your name down he was said
something along the lines of oh I know
this is the kind of leader or you can
show that you're a leader or something
yeah
I mean it's well intentioned I love Ryan
even hearing it you know I this is in my
pre-game interviews but being
mansplained you was one of my pet peeves
so I
I just have to laugh at it because I'm
like it's coming from a place of like
love and well-intentioned but it's it's
so funny because it's just I know
I got a check sister that was hilarious
it's like so have you embraced yourself
and like the leader that you are and I'm
like
yeah I should remind myself and my in my
day to day I need to remind myself to do
that exactly exactly yeah I felt the
same way I was like huh what did he
saying yeah
oh so good
um so now you are the first official
member of the jury what's it like
sitting in that jury spot and now being
able to observe tribal councils
um from the Jersey or from where I am at
home like from when you're we're on the
show so like when you're on the jury
like what's it like being that person
able to actually see it unfold
oh my God it's it's like honestly the I
the ideal would be to be in the game of
course of course the second best is to
be on the jury because you're just
watching with popcorn you're just taking
it all in and
um and I also think it's it's incredible
to be able to still have a say in the
game like the agency of the vote at the
end of it it's like okay I honestly
probably had more power on the jury than
I did in the last few days while I was
out there so yeah yeah absolutely and
that's totally a great way to look at it
too so we love the positive outlook
um and I'm excited to see what happens
with you and whoever else joins the jury
so wrapping this all up although your
dream of Survivor didn't exactly play
out the way that you wanted it to was
your journey on the show and on Survivor
everything you would have hoped it would
be besides obviously winning
a hundred percent a hundred thousand ten
percent the relationships I now have
coming out of it are invaluable and it
also gives me kind of Goosebumps because
I was listening to my interviews before
the game started and the goals that I
had going in I accomplished like my
three main things that I wanted to come
out of the game were
being able to play like myself like
giving myself the freedom to play as I
am I did that not being the first boot
um and then making it to the jury it's
like kind of again it makes me have to
do something like I really just made
that goal and those were my three goals
going in and everything from there was
kind of like additive and I think
um yeah that's that's where I I'm so
grateful for the experience and being
able to share this with my dad
especially is such a super fan
um but yeah that's all to say I'm like
not hungry to play again I am
um we'll have bigger and better goals if
I ever get to play again but um I did
and feel satisfied with where I am
oh that's amazing well thank you so much
for chatting with us I'm excited you're
still going to be there you're still
going to be on the screen once in a
while on finale if you're voting for who
will win so thank you so much um and it
was lovely chatting with you thank you
just supporting me and the beers I don't
know like yeah it means a lot that you
um
wanted me to see me go far you know what
like a lot of I'm sad that a lot of the
women are being like kind of knocked off
it sucks because I love you I love
Lindsay and like I love the women on the
season were amazing so although it's
disappointing to see them go it's I'm
glad I'm able to talk to everyone and
you know let them know how I felt about
them so yeah thank you all right thank
you so much